another day another sexual assault
allegation against Alabama Republican
Senate candidate Roy Moore a lifelong
man of God and constitutional
conservative I can't even get through
that with a straight face Roy Moore who
once thought he might give his life to
stop gay marriage is accused now by yet
another woman Tina Johnson of a sexual
assault Tina Johnson was in Roy Moore's
law office in Gadsden Alabama with her
mother
Johnson was 28 years old at the time her
age is not the issue here it's Roy
Moore's actions that are at issue and as
soon as she walked into Roy Moore's
office she describes that Moore started
flirting with her at some point during
the meeting Roy Moore reportedly got up
from his desk came around and sat on the
desk as opposed to at his desk chair
inches from Tina Johnson's face and
started asking weird questions about
what color eyes Johnson's daughter had
and and whether Johnson's daughters I
believe it is were as pretty as she was
and as they finished up the legal
paperwork that was done in in Roy
Moore's office that day Johnson and her
mother start to leave Johnson walking
out of the office behind her mother and
as she did this Roy Moore came up behind
her as she tells the story and grabbed
her by the buttocks and she says
specifically he didn't pinch it he
grabbed it and she says that she was so
taken aback by this that she said
nothing at the time not even to her
mother although years after the incident
she told her sister about it although of
course these allegations can't be
checked or corroborated al.com looked
into whether Johnson did have the
paperwork done by Roy Moore in other
words was she actually there getting
legal services from Roy Moore and indeed
Roy Moore has his signature on the child
custody transfer that she completed with
Moore in his office on that day so
another day another accuser and the
question really becomes what's the best
scenario here and I believe that the
best scenario is whichever scenario gets
us to a Democrat taking over this Senate
seat I'm agnostic as to whether or not
Roy Moore steps aside his name is going
to be on the ballot either way the
elections only three and a half weeks
away the guy won the prime
right what will make doug jones the
victor that is the question and i want
to warn you right now do not become
complacent because of some of the polls
that are being announced that are making
headlines there's a new poll getting a
lot of attention which has Roy Moore
losing by 12 points to Doug Jones and
this poll was conducted by the National
Republican Senatorial Committee after
five women had accused Roy Moore of
pursuing them while they were teenagers
Doug Jones 51 Roy Moore 39 according to
this poll so don't pay attention to that
particular poll because there are
numerous other polls that say that this
is a close race there are other polls
that say that Roy Moore is still ahead
and you have to understand that the NR
SC which did this poll hold their
support for more and who knows what
their interests are at this point they
may be trying to publicly pull support
to show that they did the right thing
but at the same time maybe create
complacency among liberals by showing
that more is way behind I would just not
pay attention to this poll especially
since it seems to be an outlier and
there's people emailing me saying David
it's over it is not over bone bank
donate knock on doors Roy Moore happens
to be a horrible person with terrifying
politics but that aside a Democrat
taking this solid Republican Senate seat
that was vacated remember as a result of
Donald Trump's choice of Jeff Sessions
for attorney general this would be a
major victory for Democrats to tack on
to the recent wins earlier this month so
pay no attention to the poll pay lots of
attention to the growing list of
accusers of sexual assaults against Roy
Moore the video you just watched was
made possible by support from you please
go to patreon.com slash david pakman
show you can make a pledge of as little
as $1 per month and every dollar helps
to support the work that we're doing
particularly in light of the YouTube ad
boycott which has been really bad